we'll see you at seven  but before we let you go it's december  1st so rabbit rabbit  john has no idea what i'm talking about  you guys heard me you guys heard me  saying i don't know what that is but  everybody's tweeting at me rabbit rabbit  vlad and i'm like what is that it's good  luck you're supposed to say to the  beginning of each month oh rabbit rabbit  then rabbit rabbit people wow i had no  idea rabbit rabbit tea y'all i'm right  with you vlad now you know we'll see you  in a bit bye vlad to see the guys back  in town it really is wait so you guys  haven't heard rabbit rabbit either have  never heard it  all right this side here we got it okay  i i hope our month is luckier now for  december  good luck  [Music]